[Music]
how are you guys doing
this is insha allah the first of a
series of correction videos which we'll
be putting forward insha'allah about dr
jordan peterson's content especially in
relation to islam now for those who know
we were meant to be having me and dr
jordan peterson a discussion
and this discussion was meant to happen
actually three times and it was
cancelled unfortunately that many times
in a span of six months
now
for whatever reason in fact the third
reason was or the third time he gave me
the reason that
it was because he had other guests and
other topics that he wanted to kind of
speak about but no problem i know that
dr jordan peterson may be watching this
now since he we've had such
communication for
with his team and with himself for over
a long span of time so this is the first
and probably one of the most important
videos about some of the wording that dr
jordan peterson has decided to use
about the prophet
muhammad in
his public output this is probably the
most developed speech he has on the
topic so let's see what he has to say
and come back and commentate on it if
you look at the figure of christ and i
don't care if you're religious or not
and i don't even care if christ existed
or not and i certainly don't care at the
moment about
claims to divinity or the lack thereof
i'm just speaking as let's say i'm
speaking as a secular intellectual
i mean as a figure
he's a figure of peace i don't think
that that's
disputable
i mean he certainly he wasn't a warlord
that's that's one thing that's for
certain he never led armies
you know whereas that's not the case
with muhammad at all muhammad was
clearly and indisputably a warlord
and so it isn't obvious to me what to
make of that
except that it's bloody complicated well
i think the first thing we have to do is
define what a warlord is now this is a
definition from collins
if you describe a leader of a country or
an organization as a warlord collins
tells us you are critical of them
because they have achieved power by
behaving in an aggressive and violent
way
kimberly martin in
a
piece that she wrote called warlordism
in comparative perspective this is in
political science literature she
actually defines warlord in four
different ways
she says number one that they are they
trained army uh armed men to take
advantage of the disintegration of a
central authority to seize control over
relatively small slices of territory
number two she says that their actions
are based on self-interest not ideology
number three their authority is based on
charisma and patronage
ties to their followers and number four
this personalistic rule leads to the
fragmentation of political and economic
arrangements across the country
so these are if we look at this now
we've got one dictionary definition
obviously you can look at other
dictionaries but we have one if you want
to call it that terminological
definition from the literature from the
political science
literature now jordan peterson is famous
for saying you have to be precise in
speech i want to say to jordan peterson
that unfortunately according to these
two definitions using the term warlord
is not precise because in fact
the prophet would be disqualified from
being a warlord as per those definitions
why so because the prophet muhammad
how did he achieve power
now we have to look at obviously you
have the meccan period and the medinan
period this is the
kind of categorization the biographical
categorization of the prophet's life you
had two major or his premiership as a
prophet
his time as a prophet he had the meccan
period 13 years and then 10 years in the
medina period
when the prophet was migrating or when
he was being boycotted and persecuted
and this we know in the seerah in the
biography of the prophet
was he was being persecuted his friends
and followers were being persecuted in
in mecca for 13 years
there was then a transition period where
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
peace and blessings be upon him
try to religiously incentivize groups
and tribes outside of mecca in order to
move away and to move his followers away
from such boycott and persecution that
they were facing for a very long span of
time so he went to taif which is
a place outside of mecca and he was he
was he was rejected fiercely
i mean this is the thing about the
prophet muhammad you have to humanize
him because he was a man
who was an orphan okay think about this
for a second he was a man who was an
orphan he was a man who buried all of
his children except for one
he was a man
who
who his wife died khadija
his uncle died
talib who was one of the most
protective and actually the central
protective figure in his life and this
was in the meccan period and he wasn't
even a muslim by the way and when that
protection went away he had to then seek
it from other places so he went to
tariff
and taif was
a neighboring city
and they rejected him fiercely and if
you look at the the reports of that they
threw stones at him they taunted him he
was bleeding
so much so that his sandals were filled
with blood
this is the person you're talking about
as being a warlord and then after that
when he was rejected from that
particular city he went to
another place which was then called
yathrib
which would then be called medina where
two tribes or clans called
now these two tribes they accepted the
message of islam
and then they decided to put the prophet
as the leader of the polity of yathrib
so he was made into the leader of the
polity of yathrib
not through aggression or violence but
through popular support and this
disqualifies him from being
according to the dictionary definition
that we've just seen and in fact
according to the terminological
definition that we've also just seen as
well so this is in fact jordan peterson
and this is very important for you
because it's one of your rules in your
book
this is imprecise speech
it is imprecise imprecise speech in
accurate speech
and what is really
incumbent upon you i think from an
intellectual perspective
is for you to make a formal retraction
about this to say actually i used in
precise speech because i used one aspect
of this man's life inaccurately to
typify his whole character
and by the way
warlords and i've looked at a lot of
your videos because remember we were
meant to be speaking to each other for a
span of six months and i've seen the
majority of your videos i've seen the
majority i've read the majority of what
you've have you've written even even
peer-reviewed stuff by the way the word
warlord interestingly you have not used
it with any to my knowledge any other
person except for the prophet muhammad
so if it was about leading armies then
why not use that with harry truman who
detonated bombs
uh on on japan hiroshima and nagasaki
why not use it with winston churchill
who led campaigns in dresden and hamburg
in world war ii
okay and which which was targeting
civilians the prophet muhammad
unequivocally
denied the targeting of civilians so why
only use it
with the prophet muhammad why have you
never used it on your public output on
your books
with any other figure except for the
prophet muhammad
what kind of
exceptionalism is this
fetishization is this what kind of
exoticism is this
what kind of western gays is this
orientalizing the narrative is this
you gotta think about this because if it
was about leading armies
then all of these other figures also led
armies
more so the biblical figures joshua
moses they led armies but when you
mentioned their name you don't
automatically it doesn't spew off your
tongue the term warlord so why is it the
case
that you've made this exception for the
prophet muhammad
you are a clinical psychologist
you're a clinical psychologist jordan
peterson and you also profess
self-professed ignorance on the religion
of islam
the fact that you've used the term
warlord
to define the prophet muhammad as an
adjective as a primary adjective when it
comes to the prophet muhammad is almost
equivalent to you with a limited data
set of information as a clinical
psychologist labeling a client or a
patient of yours
that is the equivalent now what would
happen if you did that in practice you
would be shunned
you would be not except how can you how
can you label someone after or only
gathering very limited information about
them so is this a cognitive bias that
exists within you
and you have to ask yourself this
question because it's some kind of a
projection or a scapegoating of the
prophet muhammad and islam
or is it because you're trying to
energize your base
which is an alt-right base or is it
because you're trying to perpetuate a
clash of civilization's narrative or is
it because of genuine ignorance in
either or any of these situations what
is once again incumbent upon you jordan
peters and i say this
through or out of genuinity
honestly and authenticity
i think what is incumbent upon you and i
know you're watching this i know you're
listening to this
is that you make an official retraction
of this statement
otherwise you're going to have so many
variables which we've just mentioned
that you will not be able to explain
that you've used this term with the
prophet and you've not used it with any
other
political leader
this is
unjustifiable to say the least you've
not used it even with biblical prophets
which led armies so once again it's
unjustifiable
now let's move on to the second part of
this which is your comparison your false
comparison with all jew respect
your false comparison of the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
jesus christ
now the first thing is you said that
jesus was a figure of peace now we agree
with that we love jesus christ as
muslims
because we must believe that jesus
christ was a prophet a messenger and the
messiah we must believe in all of that
however
the question of him being a figure of
peace really depends upon your
interpretation
and if one was going to have a segmented
decontextualized and uncharitable
reading of jesus christ
in the christian tradition okay then one
could come to the conclusion that he was
not a figure of peace i'll tell you how
point number one
jesus christ as christologically or
understood
christologically in this in the sense
that protestants and catholics
understand him to be
is inseparable from the rest of the
trinity
as such all of those massacres that you
see in the old testament
of the canaanites and the amalekites and
so on
are or would be commanded by jesus
christ according to this christiological
understanding now let me give you one
example a very famous verse i'll read it
word for word so once again i'm not
misquoting anything
now first time it was 15 3 okay
very famous uh commandment in the old
testament
now go attack the amalekites
and totally destroy all that belongs to
them do not spare them put to death men
and women children and infants cattle
and sheep camels and donkeys
i would love for anybody to be able to
find a single hadith or a single verse
of the quran
which states
these categories of people to be killed
in fact the opposite is there
the opposite is in the hadith you are
not allowed to kill children you are not
allowed to kill non-combatant
disbelievers as the prophet muhammad
whoever kills a non-combatant not
disbeliever he will not smell the
fragrance of heaven
this is so these categories of people
it's there in the old testament and
according to the christological
understanding jesus is not to be
separated from the rest of the trinity
so that's the first thing you must say
that's the old testament and this is one
of many verses i can pull out you know
you can go on google and see how many
verses there are like this
of genocide and massacring
that's the first thing the second thing
is well look at jesus himself once again
we're being uncharitable here if one is
being uncharitable and decontextual one
may pull out something from john chapter
2 verse 15
where it states so he made a whip out of
courts and drove them from the temple
courts both sheep and cattle he
scattered the coins of of the money uh
changes and overturned their tables this
is violent behavior someone can say
a skeptic can say this look at him he's
whipping people in the temple or he's
turning the table jesus is being very
violent
according to the new testament
and this is in his own life
so once again is this a figure of peace
once again if we had an uncharitable
decontextualized segmented understanding
one can say this is not a figure of
peace actually because this is qualifies
him of being a figure what doesn't
what it what are the limits to this term
figure of peace do you have to be a
pacifist well does one have to be a
pacifist to be a figure of peace what if
someone engages more does that
disqualify them for being a figure of
peace that's another thing third thing
is book of revelation now in the
eschaton
eschatologically when jesus christ comes
back
he will
he will let's see what he does coming
out of his mouth is a sharp sword with
which to strike down the nations he will
rule them with an i inceptor
he treads
the wine press of the fury of the wrath
of god almighty
so he's going to come back and be
violent now
these these are things you may say well
i don't these are just interpretations
of the bible i i know that you have a
spiritual kind of metaphorizing approach
to the biblical text i'm very aware of
that and you may say that that's not the
way the historical jesus which
i look at or that how i interpret jesus
christ but then i have to say to you
john prism
with all due respect your interpretation
of jesus christ
is irrelevant in the grand scheme of the
christological understanding in for 2000
years of history
church fathers up until present-day
people
um scholars of christianity interpret
these things as literal okay
scholars of christianity almost
as a consensus a matter of consensus
agree
that jesus is inseparable from the
trinity so he would be implicated in uh
telling people to to to genocide people
in the village
people uh christians from the church
fathers until this present day believe
that jesus is going to have a second
coming and it will be a physically
violent second coming and if you want
resources or references of this they are
very easy to come by so once again this
fake dualism with all due respect all
due respect this didactic representation
this um
dichotomy that you've created figure of
peace versus warlord
it's like a deck of cards if you just
pull one card out falls over it's a
false comparison and it relies upon
uncharitable cherry-picked examples of
the text and this requires a retraction
as well in order for with all due
respect one's
intellectual integrity to be maintained
i think at least you should say i
suspend judgment until i've done more
investigation this is the second point
the third point i must say is and this
is the last point i will be making why
compare
what muslims consider as a prophet with
what christians consider as a god
let me say that one more time muslims
believe that prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is the final prophet
they believe that he is the final
prophet of a long list of prophets
abraham moses jesus yes as well jesus
yes the messiah and the prophet muhammad
we believe that he is um
he was sent for all of humanity as the
quran states we have not sent you except
for all of humanity
but christians believe on the other hand
and this by christians i mean here the
vast majority of them across time and in
today's demography
believe that jesus is god
so why are you comparing a prophet
to a god
these are it's not like for like
comparison unless what and this ironic
one has to come into what would at least
be more commensurate with an islamic
understanding of who jesus was which is
a man not a god
in order for you to make that comparison
see subconsciously you're thinking i'm
doing a man-to-man comparison or
unconsciously let's use exactly
the psychoanalytic freudian terms
subconsciously is a vernacular term
right
um speaking to a psychologist so i have
to keep everything tight but what i'm
saying is maybe unconsciously you've
understood that this is a man and this
is a man and we can make a comparison
like for like but according to the
christological understanding
he is a man prophet muhammad sorry yes
prophet muhammad and jesus is a god
what you should be doing if you're being
theologically consistent is comparing
allah to jesus
allah
and the quran is the god of the creator
of the heavens and the earth which we
don't believe can be divided into father
son and holy spirit this is our major
quarrel with christians theological
quarrel this is a bone of contention
we believe that allah
is the creator of all things
that it's not conceivable or
intelligible or pardonable that anybody
with a date of birth can be called god
and that jesus is therefore disqualified
from being god and by the way i think
many christians listening to me right
now resonate with what i'm saying and
you know it and you even resonate with
it they resonate with the fact that
calling a man god god man
this is something which is
unintelligible in the mind of human
beings
and this is the real bone of contention
so why make this false comparison
between christ
who is according to the christian
tradition a god and muhammad who is
according to the islamic tradition a man
in the first place may it be because you
have already accepted the islamic
premise that both of them are men
and if so you're a step closer to islam
and therefore i'm going to end with this
really i invite you to really think
about
islam as a true system
as a true system as a paradigm
replacement
to the christian
system because that might be what you're
looking for
it in fact might be what you need jordan
peterson but at the very least
at the very least jordan peterson do me
one favor
do the right thing and make a retraction
on this point
that
the point of warlord this comparison
say that this is a hasty generalization
it was in your words and you said this
in your book by the way
your newest book 12 rules
it's a low resolution blanket statement
a hyper simplification
you this is your this is your words not
mine a hyper simplification
think about it
you